this is miles kwok an exiled chinese
billionaire who at the peak of his
career
was a 73rd richest person in china and
this is what he had to say about jack ma
almost exactly two years before he
disappeared
i think him is only two way all the
china has a billionaire
only two way i always call one year only
two things happen
jail jail and that's dead
he's either going to jail or he's going
to be killed i just think of food
or you might just fall off a wall yes or
you might just fall off the wall
and die when we jail another we kill you
everybody seems a resource no doubt
that is a that is a prediction that our
audience
is going to also have a very hard time
with
you know what i have a hard time with
the fact that i loved eating cereal as a
kid
until i found out just how much sugar
and artificial stuff they pack into it
so if you're like me you have big goals
in life in business and in health you
need to be at your peak performance at
all times
but you enjoy the smaller things in life
like a delicious bowl of cereal as a
midnight snack that is where
magic spoon comes in healthy cereal that
tastes literally too good to be true
it is the only cereal i eat because it
has 11 grams of protein low carbs and
it's just as addicting
and satisfying as the big food brands
you had as a kid
oh my god that's good
my favorite flavors are cocoa chocolate
fruity loops of fruit and of course my
beloved cinnamon
and you badass viewers have been loving
it too you can get all those flavors and
more with their build your own box
feature
get five dollars off for a limited time
by going to magicspoon.comtran with code
jake tran with the link below
they have a risk-free 100 happiness
guarantee so you can get your money back
if you're not satisfied
so get your five dollars off with the
link below
[Music]
december 10 2015
also known as the warren buffett of
china disappears
we do not know what is happening in his
case he truly has vanished according to
zai shin magazine well founded the fosun
group
a mega conglomerate an investment
company with over a hundred billion
dollars in assets
their portfolio includes big pharma in
china and india insurance companies
hospital chains in portugal the atlantis
resort national banks and even a 25
stake in circuit day soleil and in 2020
their main subsidiary fosan
international
ranked number 371 on the forbes global
2000 list
making him the 17th richest man in china
in 2015
and yet on december 10 2015 gwao dropped
off the face of the earth
infosound executives reported that they
lost contact with their boss
day 2 fosun group's house trading on
both the hong kong and shanghai stock
exchange
pending the release of an announcement
containing inside information
the company said that gua was assisting
in certain investigations carried out by
mainland judicial authorities
the company also mentioned that they
were in contact with wow just
through appropriate channels day three
or four
fulson group held a conference call
where one of the shareholders asked if
that meant they were talking to go out
directly or through an intermediary
possibly a government intermediary the
question was left unanswered
january 7 2016 almost exactly a month
after guavas disappeared sent shockwaves
through the chinese business community
cho ching zhang billionaire fashion
entrepreneur also disappears
joe has a classic rags to riches story
but in this case the rags part is quite
literal
he tried his hand at carpentry
bricklaying and finally as a tailor
he got his savings confiscated by the
government at 14 basically going
bankrupt
and eventually ciao founded one of
china's best known fashion brands
metho's boneway
which targets college students and grads
with a cheaper alternative to brands
like h m and zara
making him the 62nd richest man in china
in 2015
and much like the last guy on january 7
2016
the company said they were unable to
reach him or the secretary of the board
they halted their training on the
shenzhen stock exchange and reports came
out that chao was picked up by police
[Music]
january 2017 billionaire financer
xiao jianwa who has ties to the xi
jinping family
gets rolled away in a wheelchair with
his head covered by five or six
unmarked chinese public security agents
he was not known to use a wheelchair
xiao controls the tomorrow group a
holdings company with interest insurance
companies banks and real estate
developers
at the time his net worth was six
billion dollars
paranoid about other billionaires that
went missing xiao and other chinese
tycoons got out of the mainland and
hidden hotels like the four seasons in
hong kong
where these tycoons were believed to
have rented out entire floors at six to
twenty six
thousand dollars per month and at 1am on
the eve of chinese new year's
five or six agents of china's equivalent
to the cia abducted them to the mainland
later xiao called his family to tell him
he was taken to the mainland but that he
was fine
his company posted on social media that
he was just over there for medical
treatment and that he would return
soon and he posted on social media
denying that he was abducted and how he
was
innocent that post was later deleted
this mo of getting abducted then telling
the world i'm fine nothing to see here
is pretty common among chinese business
people
march 2020 real estate mogul ran
chi-chong
posted a brutal essay online hating on
the great leader in the chinese
communist party's handling of the virus
it included baseless insults like if
there was freedom of speech citizens
would take active measures to protect
themselves
or when shameless and ignorant people
attempt to resign themselves to the
stupidity of the great leader
society becomes a mob that's hard to
develop and sustain
and plenty of other anti-communists
rhetoric that have no basis in reality
so starting on march 12th ren was
understandably never heard from again
and his weibo account which had 37
million followers
is now deleted
now out of these four billionaires that
went away how many do you think came
back
two two came back one was sentenced to
prison
another one never reappeared in the
public eye the real estate mogul who
caught the president a clown in that
essay was missing for seven months
and in september 2020 he magically
reappeared to be sentenced to 18 years
in prison
the charge corruption of course taking
bribes and abusing his power among other
things
in which he conveniently confessed to
all his crimes in a voluntary
and truthful manner his assets were also
seized and he was fined 4.2 million yuan
billionaire financier xiao the guy that
was wheeled away on a wheelchair
his fate is not very clear because since
his abduction way back in january 2017
his whereabouts are still unknown and he
hasn't reappeared in the public eye
and the government recently started
dismantling his financial empire by
seizing hundreds of billions worth of
his companies and assets
so things are not looking good for show
for the ones that did make it back
into society the warren buffett of china
and the fashion entrepreneur
both never spoke a word about their
leave of absence
and acted as if nothing happened these
are just four examples we're not even
including all the lesser known people
that have disappeared journalists
publishers activists smaller
millionaires
and of course the latest example being
jack ma
october 24th 2020 jack ma delivers a
speech at the bun finance summit in
shanghai
since then you guessed it he's nowhere
to be found
with the only clue to his worry about
being a three paragraph article from
cnbc stating that the billionaire is not
missing
instead ma has been lying low for the
time being according to a person
familiar with the matter
but general robert spalding doesn't buy
it he's the author of the book stealth
war
china's silent takeover while america's
elite slept
so it is likely that he meant
the same fate as other billionaires have
in
in that he was basically he ran afoul of
the party and he's probably
most likely in some form of
house arrest somewhere within china
where he he's no longer allowed to to
leave the confines
of his living space so a report came out
recently that there was a rumor that he
was laying low
but you think it's more likely house
arrest well he could be laying low
but it seems awfully improbable
that he would cease all you know
appearances in public voluntarily
i mean he is one of the richest guys in
china
he's also well respected as an
entrepreneur an innovator
um so the idea that he would just stop
all of a sudden being public possible
but it is more likely that he you know
met the fate of many other billionaires
under xi jinping which is
he was he was forced into some kind of
um
lockdown after all as you know this
pattern of disappearing then telling
people you're okay when you're not
is what we've seen in previous examples
[Music]
obviously due to the pandemic this is on
a video link so we're not still clear
exactly where
the founder of alibaba is but it is the
first sighting since
early november
now one would think jack speech must
have been pretty spicy pretty brutal
against the ccp
but if you read the translation it's not
that bad
one might even call it pretty reasonable
he eases in by saying that these are
just the non-professional views of a
non-professional person
and that his opinions may be immature
incorrect or laughable
with the main message being that for the
sake of china for the prosperity of
china
china and the world needs a new
financial system and that china's
current banking system operates with a
pawn shop mentality
that chinese regulators are outdated
that we cannot use the way to manage a
railway station to manage an airport
and he hinted at how xi jinping isn't
bearing the responsibility of
innovation and the mistakes that come
with it so definitely not the most
politically smart move by jack ma
but also nowhere near the real estate
mogul calling xi jinping a clown calling
for horrible things like freedom of
speech
and it's also nowhere near the level of
criticism business leaders in america
say about their government on a regular
basis
this is like if jeff bezos or elon musk
went missing after criticizing the us
government
so the question remains why do chinese
billionaires keep disappearing
during the mid 1900s there was no such
thing as private businesses or private
enterprise in china
it was pure communism there was no
private enterprise
allowed whatsoever in fact they had like
collective
communes really for people you know
essentially
shared labor to grow their crops
the problem was those plops kept dying
from starvation
and poor central planning and over the
time that mao sedona was in charge
millions of people tens of millions of
people died in china because of the
economy's inability to
create enough sustenance for the people
after the main leader mao zedong died
his successor started allowing a little
capitalism into the mix while still
maintaining absolute control
it doesn't matter if the cat is white or
black as long as it catches mice
so this allowed some limited
private sector activity within the
chinese economy
and what started out as a little private
enterprise has slowly grown into what
china is today
which is kind of this mix of
authoritarianism
and capitalism but capitalism that's
very
much constrained by
the things that the chinese communist
party wants why
because our great leaders realize that
if we don't feed our people
if we don't give them some prosperity
they're going to keep starving to death
revolt or the world will condemn us and
not take us seriously or trade with us
and we won't be able to keep up with the
rest of the world either way complete
suffering threatens our rule
which is obviously the only thing that
matters since pure communism doesn't
seem to be working
it's in our best interest to allow our
subjects to create businesses to create
jobs to cultivate resources
as long as they don't threaten our power
the way that the chinese communist party
system works
is they want to give you some amount of
freedom because
that unlocks economic activity you know
your pursuit of wealth
as an individual actually is the force
that deng xiaoping unleashed the problem
with giving some economic freedom is
that your subjects might take it a
little bit too far they might get a
little too ambitious
so if they end up threatening your power
that is when the sickle comes down
now what comes with opening up and
giving
people a little bit of freedom as they
begin to
take that freedom farther than the
chinese communist party is willing to
allow
and that's exactly what happened to
billionaires like jack ma
under xi jinping what's happened is
a lot of these reforms that that began
under deng xiaoping continued under
zhang zaman
slowly began to be unraveled under hujin
tao
have really just sharply unraveled under
xi jinping
and that has resulted in the chinese
communist party taking a much more
direct control over
businesses one of the things that's
happening to a lot of these
previously you know very wealthy
business owners and
and like jack ma former ceos is that xi
jinping is cracking down on all of them
and when he made that statement he
basically made himself an enemy of the
of the chinese communist party so if
this is the case
if you're an aspiring entrepreneur in
china why would you want to start
business if you know that the ccp can
take away everything in a moment's
notice and make you disappear
what is the motivation
[Music]
it's the same motivation for places like
the us in the meantime
those entrepreneurs are ritually
rewarded by having preferential
treatment from the government in terms
of rules
and regulations but also access to
capital and
the motivation is i can get really
really wealthy
and maybe i can get really really
wealthy i can establish a nest egg
outside the country and maybe i can
actually leave the country
as many have they've moved their assets
out they've gotten rich and then they
they've escaped i know what the rules
are i would never go against the party
that would be a suicidal move that would
never happen to me
i'm not doing anything wrong the irs and
fbi would never come after me
look at all these successful business
people that are on the good side of the
party they're living the life
and so in the case of these
entrepreneurs innovators
these ceos these tech ceos it is likely
that they're aware of the challenges
uh you know to to countering the chinese
communist party
but you know it's one of those things
well it's never going to happen to me
yeah it happened to somebody else but
you know it's not going to happen to me
because i'm not going to do something
that you know gets me in trouble the
problem with this line of thinking is
when you get super big and eventually
break the laws of power without even
realizing it
the moment you threaten the rule the
moment you outshine them the moment you
have just a little bit too much
influence over your fans
they're gonna have their sights on you
you know the the party
if they recognize somebody as having
more public exposure
than say the political leaders in the
case of jack ma
he was very very popular
he had a big following he was a very
successful businessman
you know as that stature becomes
something that could become a political
problem for the chinese communist party
it is the case that you might do things
exactly
like like you were doing before in other
words you're not saying anything
different or doing every anything
different
it's just that the party has come to see
you as an adversary to the party
and so you may think it's not going to
happen to me
because i ain't know where the limits
are and i'm not going to cross that
boundary
but what happens is a party if the party
begins to see you
as a threat the the limits
change and they may change in a way
that's imperceptible to you that you may
not even be aware of so you may not
do anything different than what you did
before
but the party has viewed you as an
adversary and then you do something
that kind of triggers that reactiveness
and then the party will come after you
and so it is likely that
um these these people aren't
trying to get themselves in trouble
because they understand
the power that the kind chinese
communist party has
over the country it is just that the
party has changed its view
regarding them and if you're the type of
person that isn't politically attuned
if you make it to the top you are going
to get screwed
certainly under xi jinping you know any
business
leader now needs to be strictly strictly
thinking about
the party and how they promote the party
and how they're
loyal to the party now that is not
something that these entrepreneurs like
jack ma
have been used to they've been used to
be having more freedom
to go out and build their business
that's not the china that exists today
and even if you do make your money and
get out of china your fate
is still uncertain what china has been
doing
and the car in the chinese communist
party has been using the ministry of
state security
which is their equivalent of the cia to
go around the world
and try to abduct these people and bring
them back to china and they've been
very successful at doing that so i heard
it happened to one guy in hong kong
where he was abducted and taken back so
it happens all over the world too not
just hong kong
even in the united states in fact it was
happening
regularly during the obama
administration
that the ministry of state security was
essentially going throughout the united
states and
you know basically taking chinese back
to china wow
that's crazy it is crazy and scary
all right guys here's the situation so i
just got back from jiu jitsu like a few
hours ago
pretty exhausted as you can tell by like
some of the scars and scratches and
bruises i have all over me
but pretty exhausted don't really feel
like making food
and i haven't really eaten much today uh
calorie restriction and all that great
stuff
so if i were to get all the protein i
need for today
i would have to stuff my face right now
which i don't really want to do so
magic spoon comes in so we have cinnamon
here awesome
smells like cinnamon cinnamon is one of
my favorite flavors in general
and like whatever food like desserts and
stuff
so very happy to have this one
and i love the uh the popular cinnamon
cereal
that everyone knows about like toast
cinnamon crunch or whatever
as always some nice serial asmr for you
guys
oh my god that's good
one more
general robert spalding he is the guy
that you saw sprinkled though at this
video and he is also
an extremely sharp guy that i have a ton
of respect for and he wrote the book
stealth war
china silent takeover while america's
elite slept and if you want to know
about like pretty much the most
important
geopolitical situation we have going on
in the world right now
us versus china and get a really good
understanding of what people are going
to look back to as a very important
point in history i highly highly
recommend this book
really easy read extremely important
read and a very hard book to put down
that will be linked in the video
description
general spalding also has his own
youtube channel where he goes over
china-related news and his analysis of
it so that'll be linked down below for
you guys to check out as well
while you guys are down there if you are
new to this channel and you're not
subscribed already
what are you doing because we make video
essays just like this one every single
week
for free on this channel so make sure
you subscribe with the button below
alright one last shameless plug for you
guys i am so close
to not being pleb anymore on instagram
you guys got to help me get to
10 000 followers on instagram so that
will be linked below for you guys to
check out we post
memes me complaining about stuff cool
quotes i come across in my research that
you're not going to hear anywhere else
behind the scenes stuff day in the life
kind of stuff it's really fun help me
not be of love anymore we're so close
that is going to wrap it up for this
video you guys thank you so much for
watching oh yeah if you want to support
this channel financially magic spoon
magic spoon you guys can check this out
with the link below five dollars off
that is actually gonna wrap it up for
today's video thank you so much for
watching stay dangerous out there
and i will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you